die negativ schlagzeilen rund um
verbrennungsmotoren reißen einfach
nicht ab ist jetzt vielleicht endlich
die stunde der elektro auto zu bekommen
also für die elektrische revolution die
absatzzahlen sprechen eine andere
sprache zu hoch ist der preis zum
kursbereich weise und zu umständlich
der ladevorgang noch wenn in den
nächsten jahren werden
technologiesprünge erwartet die unsere
skepsis gegenüber e autos in
begeisterung umschlagen lassen könnten
mehr darüber jetzt wirklich vom
kleinsten sind herzlich willkommen
nach frankreich wie jetzt auch
großbritannien nach unsere
französischen nachbarn wollen den
verkauf von verbrennungsmotoren bis 2040
komplett einstellen auf britischen
straßen sollen dann nur noch
elektroautos zugelassen werden in
deutschland ist ein deutscher plan noch
zukunftsmusik und auf deutschen straßen
kommen elektroautos auch nicht so
wirklich ins rollen woran es liegt die
große skepsis der deutschen wenn es um
elektroautos geht an der auswahl der
elektrofahrzeuge kann es inzwischen
nicht mehr liegen 100 einträge zählt
die liste des bundesamt für wirtschaft
und ausfuhrkontrolle
sie reicht von a wie audi bis vw golf
und fällt die verschiedenen typen von
elektrofahrzeugen auf die sich deutsche
autokäufer derzeit mit der sogenannten
elektroauto prämie zu stoppen können
doch auch wenn er angebot groß ist die
absatzzahlen der e-autos sind kaum
erwähnenswert 2016 kam voll elektrische
wagen mit batterie zusammen mit kein
elektrischen hybriden deren elektromotor
an der steckdose aufgeladen werden muss
gerade einmal auf einen marktanteil
achtung von 0,7 prozent dagegen gut drei
millionen neue fahrzeuge mit
gewöhnlichen verbrennungsmotoren
verkauft einen anteil von rund 98
prozent in verschiedenen befragungen
geben wir deutschen anders und vor allem
der kaufpreis abschreckt auch eine zu
geringe reichweite und eine schlechte
infrastruktur was die lage
möglichkeiten der e autos angeht hält
die befragten davon ab den kauf eines e
autos überhaupt in betracht zu ziehen
das alles sind aspekte die bei einer
kaufentscheidung einfach überwiegen und
zwar zurecht und da sowohl so viele
deutsche in ihrem sonstigen alltags
umweltbewusst und grün handeln
doch experten sagen rasante entwicklung
für die kommenden jahrzehnte voraus die
opec sagt für das jahr 2040 und 266
million stromer auf den straßen browser
plugin autos also rein und teil
elektrische fahrzeuge mit extern
aufladbaren batterien sollen dann ein
drittel des weltweiten bestandes
ausmachen ihre prognosen für die zu
erwartende zahl der diesel fahrzeuge im
jahr 2040 haben die wirtschaftsexperten
stattdessen halbiert die vorhersagen
dieses aufwärtstrends basieren auf
technologischen innovationen in diesem
bereich
diniert mit sinkenden preisen jetzt
schon werden die batterien immer
effizienter und elektroautos wie der
opel ampera kommt mit einer ladung
bereits knapp 400 kilometer weit
doch es gibt weitere technologiesprünge
beispiel ladung das kalifornische
unternehmen cor kommen will das
induktive auflagen populär machen lager
platten auf dem supermarkt platz vor der
ampel oder verbaut in die autobahn in
der zukunft bräuchte er auch so keine
riesigen batterien mehr um genügend
reichweite für den nachhauseweg zu
haben dadurch könnten sie deutlich
kostengünstiger werden schon im
kommenden jahr sollen die ersten
fahrzeuge auf dem markt kommen die sich
dann ähnlich wie eine elektrische
zahnbürste induktiv aufladen lassen
können ein großes hindernis für die
elektromobilität wäre so beseitigt
reichweite wäre kein thema mehr und
auch die großen traditionellen
autobauer selbst investieren weiter in
diese branche technologiesprung bei
toyota hier wird zurzeit eine batterie
mit einer deutlich kürzeren aufladezeit
entwickelt und selbst im motorsport wird
plötzlich ein anderer wind mercedes
will nun aus der deutschen
tourenwagen-meisterschaft aussteigen und
stattdessen abgerungen
1920 in der formel durchstarten
doch damit sich elektroautos wirklich
auf den deutschen straßen brück
durchsetzen können braucht es noch viel
mehr als technologiesprünge kleinere
preise und eine gute infrastruktur die
politische unterstützung ja und schaut
man mal in andere länder die in sachen
elektromobilität ganz weit oben sind
wird eine sache da überall dort werden
autos vom staat enorm gefördert
das ziel der deutschen bundesregierung
bis 2020 eine million elektroautos auf
die straße zu bringen aber damit werden
die politiker aller voraussicht
kläglich scheitern wenn man die
aktuellen zulassungszahlen liegt und das
würde nämlich für mich peinlich 2011
wurde dieses ziel festgeschrieben es ist
aber das papier nicht wert auf dem es
steht wirklich bemüht hat mich niemals
das ziel wirklich zu erreichen wenn
jetzt darüber beklagt wird dass die
chinesen zum weltmarktführer für
elektroautos geworden sind und die
deutschen hinterher
dann soll sich die politik mal an die
eigene nase packen wie hat es verbockt
es benötigt dann innovative unternehmen
wie die streetscooter gmbh fahren
inzwischen wurde der transporter bauer
von der deutschen post ober übernommen
die jetzt ihre eigenen elektro
transporter baut mit rund 2500
exemplaren auf platz 4 der
meistgenutzten elektroautos in
deutschland und die entwickler sind
bereits am nächsten projekt dran ab
2018 wollen sie ein super günstiges
elektroauto produzieren zum thema
technologiesprung das absolut
alltagstauglich sein soll also trotz der
politik werden sich wohl elektroautos
durchsetzen die dann hoffentlich alle
mit regenerativer energie angetrieben
werden wir halten euch dazu natürlich
wie immer auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
video verpassen wollt dann drücken wir
hier ein aber aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier geht es
weiter mit formel bahnbrechende
innovation
da war ich hier beim formel 1 rennen in
berlin absolut irre also unbedingt
anschauen sprich draufklicken ansonsten
bis dann lecker